the topic of where in Israel the United
States Embassy is has been an issue
really for years probably more than 20
years at minimum I would say and it's
been a bigger and bigger issue since
Donald Trump became president of the
United States specifically because his
appointment of David Friedman as
ambassador of the United States to
Israel came with the known desire of
David Friedman to Don not only continue
expanding settlements in Israel which is
a disaster obviously but also to move
the embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem
and yes indeed Donald Trump told both
Arab and Israeli leaders yesterday that
he plans to recognize Jerusalem as the
capital of Israel and to eventually move
the embassy there and the actual
movement of the embassy that part's
going to take a while it could take up
to six months but the recognizing of
Jerusalem as the capital would happen
immediately and that's really the
immediate controversy and I've said it
before we're talking about it so I'll
say it again it's a disastrous idea to
unilaterally move the embassy from Tel
Aviv to Jerusalem but I think it's
necessary to explain what's going on
here and why this is a huge deal people
have been emailing me saying they may
not exactly understand what the
implications are here here's one example
email I got about this from a viewer
named Matt who said hi David being
embarrassingly unaware about Middle
Eastern matters I was hoping you could
address this topic and explain the
controversy around it I really just
don't understand it and I don't even
know which questions I should be asking
to begin to educate myself for example
maybe this is a dumb question but why
does the u.s. have a say in determining
which city of a foreign country is its
capital I ask you this not because you
are ethnically Ashkenazi Jewish but
because you have a track record of
providing comprehensive explanations of
complex issues so here's the controversy
Matt to begin with and sort of set up
our discussion within Israel Jerusalem
is considered to be the capital of
Israel but Jerusalem is part of the
disputed territories in Israel which
include
the West Bank the Gaza Strip and and
even within Jerusalem it's mostly East
Jerusalem that is in dispute although as
a result the status of Jerusalem more
broadly as a capital city is in dispute
so as a result internationally Tel Aviv
which is the coastal city in Israel on
the Mediterranean Sea is considered the
capital for all intents and purposes and
the reason why moving the embassy from
Tel Aviv to Jerusalem would be
controversial and a bad idea is because
you have quite frankly an intractable
situation with peace negotiations in
Israel it's a total impasse a huge part
of which centers around land and
Jerusalem is part of that is a crucial
part of that and saying we're going to
put our embassy in Jerusalem as if it
were the undisputed capital of Israel
internationally is a total diplomatic fu
if there is such a thing as a diplomatic
fu this would be it plain and simple and
it's going to hinder what I've been
pretty clear about it are already a very
limited chances of serious peace
negotiations going forward particularly
with the people that are in power
representing Palestinians particularly
with Benjamin Netanyahu and his
far-right extremist coalition in power
in Israel the u.s. unilaterally making
the embassy move and recognizing
Jerusalem as the capital is breaking
with international consensus on
something that is just simply not
settled it is not settled in any way and
once again it's sort of like with Trump
being making the u.s. the one country
that doesn't participate in the Paris
climate Accords Trump is the guy saying
now Jerusalem is the capital will put
our embassy there now you could have a
situation where eventually as part of a
peace agreement West Jerusalem is
Israeli and East Jerusalem is
Palestinian in a non disputed sense but
that hasn't been negotiated yet we have
East Jerusalem as a days as a disputed
territory right now and this moved by
the United States will help nothing and
it's been totally written on the wall as
I said the day after Donald Trump
selected David Freedman as
to Israel an absolute and total
extremists another one of his outrageous
positions and I've mentioned this before
I want to say it again is that Freedman
is of the of the mindset that we should
be that Israel should be and the u.s.
should be indifferent to or encouraging
or allowing Israel to build more
settlements and the range of opinion on
settlements in Israel is and I'm
creating sort of a spectrum here the
settlements must be destroyed
up to the settlements that are there can
stay if there are meaningful land swaps
eventually and David Friedman is way
outside of what is already a pretty wide
spectrum of opinion on the issue of
settlement so to go back to the policy
of it Donald Trump told us Jared Kushner
is gonna go in and negotiate
israeli-palestinian peace now that's a
joke to begin with right but let's
imagine for a moment that Jared Kushner
was going to go in and negotiate
israeli-palestinian peace the United
States needs to appear to be an unbiased
broker once the u.s. unilaterally says
we recognize Jerusalem as the capital of
Israel that means we are taking aside in
a number of ways and it destroys the
Trump administration's credibility as a
possible arbiter of peace but to be
honest there was not ever really a good
shot of the Trump United States being
that arbiter of peace and nothing
changes here as far as Israel is
concerned they've seen Jerusalem as the
capital period throughout this a period
of decades it hurts the United States
and this is a completely optional way
that Donald Trump is finding to hurt the
image and credibility of the United
States around the world it's
symbolically disastrous aside from
whether there would really be credible
peace negotiations at any point optional
unforced error and even if you say that
all right we're gonna give up on
brokering a peace deal between the
Israelis and the Palestinians we're just
gonna take the Israeli side shouldn't we
be getting some concessions for this
move as well I mean where's the art of
the deal here we should be getting some
something from the Israeli government
for this right if you
our Trump and you're aligned with the
far right Benjamin Netanyahu you don't
want concessions that's it's sort of
part of the problem in other words the
rhetorical question you're asking is
correct which is if we are doing
something that presumably Israel wants
to happen which is the international
community to recognize Jerusalem as the
capital if this was an actual push-pull
negotiation we would maybe try to get
some kind of concession from Israel but
the fact that there is not even a desire
for that this is something Trump and
Friedman want that's sort of the sick
reality of it interesting yeah and I
think it also just has to do with Trump
trying to fulfill some campaign promises
like you know now maybe he can get tax
reform done or get his travel ban upheld
this is just the next thing and maybe
his voters really don't understand the
issue too complex Lee oh they don't he
does they absolutely don't and if I was
conspiratorial I'd wonder whether this
wasn't a deliberate action to flare
tensions in the Middle East and take
away attention from you know insert
scandal here and that's already
happening right this is already having a
destabilizing impact on the Middle East
turkey says that this declaration of
Jerusalem as Israel's capital is going
to start quote a fire with no end in
sight they announced that they're gonna
be hosting a meeting of Islamic nations
in the region sort of to give other
Muslim leaders other Muslim country
leaders an opportunity to create some
kind of coordinated response to this
Pope Francis said he's profoundly
concerned and appealed to the that
everyone respect the status quo of the
City of Jerusalem which is of course
disputed at this time what is the upside
here that's really my question what is
the upside is it what Pat is pointing
through that maybe it's an
accomplishment that Trump can check off
it just feels to me like fundamentally
this is so far down the list of
priorities for the Trump voters that
it's not a good one to just go
unilaterally on but maybe I'm missing
something and we'll continue to cover it
the video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership